sur la sale [ __ ] non je regarde pas du
tout parce que parce que c'est
intéressant parce que c'est quand même
il ya énormément de gens qui aiment bien
cette chanson ça a été mal interprété ça
continue encore d'être mal interprété
mais mais de là à la regrettée pas du
tout ça fait partie de ces partis plus
tard
j'ai toujours aimé la mythologie grecque
comme des petits je lisais quelques
bouquins je connais assez bien et puis
aussi avec toutes les histoires qui
autour toutes les bandes dessinées les
dessins animés ya énormément de dessins
animés de mon époque qui sont inspiré
par la mythologie à ulysse 31 et
avilissent 31 il y avait les chevaliers
du zodiaque
[Musique]
bâle ii fils de profs ou quand je parle
de profs comment vous promets je suis
prof et quand je parle des jeunes moyens
je parle de moi quand je parle des
ouvriers j'ai bossé à l' usine
[Musique]
mon premier équipe que j'avais sorti je
m'appelais au elle s'appelait ramène je
suis parti pour déposer mon nom sacem
après avoir sorti ce clip en disant
c'est bien de protéger très métriques et
ils m'ont dit en fait vous pouvez pas
déposé le nom aurel parce que c'est déjà
déposé du coup moi même parce que je
trouve un autre pseudo et tous les
bagages on a discuté on a trouvé orelsan
en trouvait ça cool parce que j'aimais
bien le japon les mangas et puis il
serait un truc un peu un powell japonais
cool quoi donc on a un sens savoir
présenter bien mon délire et donc en
fait je me suis inscrit récemment dans
qu'orelsan et un jour j'ai reçu mon
premier je suis pas ma carte
d'inscription à la sacem le sait marquer
orelsan
or elle est en fait j'ai un avis mais
pourquoi j'ai pourquoi j'ai le nom aurel
ils ont dit pas c'est vous qui l'aviez
déposé
[Musique]
enfin pouvoir quitter système de merde
après trois ans de bons et loyaux
services
[Musique]
on comprend que les paroles de la
chanson ont pu choquer certaines
personnes c'est pour ça que je la fais
pas sur scène parce que j'ai envie de
l'imposer à personne moi ce que je
voulais symbolisé dans la chanson
c'était le fait que l'être humain puisse
passer de l'amour à la haine et qu' il
ya plein de sentiments qui peuvent
rendre un être humain monstrueux
quasiment turquie puisse dire des choses
horribles des choses super violente
c'est une fiction c'est à dire que c'est
pas moi qui parle je trouve ça un peu
dommage d'être obligé de me justifier
mais évidemment je suis pas misogyne
évidemment c'est mal de frapper les gens
en général
[Musique]
il y avait un propos qui était de dire
je vais te marie trintigner qui à la
fois de violences pour la famille mais
ça n'est pas à nous en charge des droits
de la famille trintignant mais ça veut
dire que on va faire un sort à la femme
du fait de son statut de femme identique
à celui qu'a subie marie trintignant
c'est une incitation à la violence du
fait du sexe de la personne
[Musique]
jean mal et star de balayer l'histoire
d'un mec je sais que les gens ont envie
d'entendre mon point de vue là dessus
c'est vraiment un coup de pub c'est la
mauvaise pub c'est de la mauvaise puis
vous avez souffert plus tôt bas surtout
professionnellement parlant après
personnellement c'était assez
intéressant parce que du coup j'ai
compris certains rouages médiatique la
façon dont dont les gens à analyser
l'information et aux c'était assez
enrichissant mais d'un point de vue
professionnel déjà sam a annulé la
moitié de la tournée donc ça fait
quarante une quarantaine de dates donc
déjà je fais de la musique pour faire
des concerts canton années de la moitié
de la tournée c'est forcément pénalisant
[Musique]
me demande souvent si c'est une revanche
mais c'est pas une revanche parce que je
suis pas dans une bataille n'est rien
c'est pas si je suis pas en guerre c'est
quelque chose qui me fait plaisir et
voilà
mais de remercier les gens avec qui je
bosse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est l'histoire de deux mecs qui
doivent faire une chanson ils ont 24
heures pour faire cette chanson mais les
gars c'est des branleurs et eux mêmes
savent pas vraiment s'ils veulent faire
de la musique où ils sont ils sont dans
une sorte d'entre deux âges quoi ça
parle vraiment cette période
tu sais pas trop quoi faire de ta vie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la fête est finie c'est quand même un
peu prendre ses responsabilités arrêtez
de faire un peu les mêmes erreurs tu
vois que ça des erreurs graves ou c'est
pas si grave que ça basique
[Musique]
tapez l'argent qu'ils utilisent même
dans dans des postes dans des mêmes dans
des trucs où je suis plus dans les gens
disent basique simple maintenant qu'il
ya basique et un simple derrière et ça
c'est vrai que je m'y attendais pas
[Musique]